there's any truth that Ronda is going to
w/e Ronda Rousey's they've been talking
about that for a while I think it's
inevitable I really do I think it's
inevitable that she will do something
she's got the great personality showbiz
personality she's got box-office sizzle
she has sold paper views there will be
people that have bought her USC paper
views that will go to the WV network to
our pay-per-view to watch her at receive
a Wrestlemania because she has a track
record of she has customer base she has
a fan base the question is I believe
that those MMA fans that loved her will
follow her for her first major event in
WWE that is my take on it
so I think it's inevitable so you think
it's inevitable she goes there yeah she
also loves wrestling I mean rowdy roddy
piper was her it was it was an idol of
hers and she's a mainstream star - right
so it's not just the MMA fans oliver
people that are just curious at this
sheezus article that is Ronda Rousey
Sheamus and I think some day Conor
McGregor will be at WWE
you know what it wouldn't surprise me if
he did considering the money right now
the amount of money he could probably
get has she been training and wrestling
I heard she has been training
she has been I think Nattie Neidhart has
been doing a little a tutoring of her
Nattie a restaurant at E Stu Hart's
granddaughter one of my favorites but
she's Ron is a group cool lady yes she's
good man I like her and I big fan of her
stuff and I and she's you know we signed
they signed one of her her buddies
Shayna Baszler yeah and she was in the
finals of the myun tournament that WWE
had I worked with Lita so that MMA
influence is kind of seeping in a little
bit because they have good mat skills
and what they did is so logical they're
not looking to the next spot or the next
move they're actually wrestling and do
you think is there any timeframe on her
because she's been out it's been a while
since she lost I saw I saw some video on
her a few days ago she looked awesome
she did so I think she's diligent what
she's doing and I think she's also that
athlete and in her that she didn't want
to look bad
the young female Hollywood feel but also
a great athlete she's gonna say I want
to stay in shape because she's not the
kind of person if you'll say oh look
we're on the realtor self go right
yeah she's 230 I also think MMA has
changed the way people look at
a fight is supposed to look like I think
that's why I like it's all kind of
seeped into the world of pro wrestling
because like kicks are much bigger now
submissions are a much bigger deal now
you know choke outs in in the early days
of my career the wrestling hierarchy
would never allow a star fan-favorite a
babyface to lose by submission it's a
bad message to the kids that you quit
because it it was it was totally
unrealistic made no sense
sure so now anybody can lose by
submission at any time because it is a
proven finish sure I like that it's
pretty yes proving that like really you
know a very tough men will submit you
know so there's no there's no disgrace
in and I think what's helped wrestling -
I like the crossover back and forth
because guys like Brock who people guy
he's a wrestler you know he was an
animal in MMA he was a very very tough
guy and he beat some really tough guys
and even though CM Punk lost to mickey
Gaul he still he still came out and is
very dedicated absolutely people even
MMA fans have a lot of respect for him
you know sorry Sam yeah you had a big
deep breath there and I was going I want
to say that I really admire Phil Brooks
CM punk for what he put his body through
the weight weight cut you know every
lifestyle changes and to the degree of a
fighting training fighter yeah and to go
into a area where he's gonna have a huge
microscope on him with where people most
a lot of the MMA people are wanting him
to get his ass whipped
yeah 37 years old fighting a much
younger guy jujitsu brown belt you know
yeah it was a really ballsy thing
decision to fight again till he still I
don't doubt it a bit and in I think he's
just he's gotta get out of the system
and I he's got any he'll do well is
whatever he does I've missed him in
wrestling because he's goddamn
entertaining if he wanted to go back
hoodie oh yeah I think so you know I'm
not making Dunham speak for the boss but
or anybody a trip relating those guys
but if this if the pavement was back
smooth and there was communication
that's all viable honest upfront
communication by everybody involved I
don't see any reason why I couldn't come
back he's a guy who's like a lot of guys
are able just to forgive and forgetting
all right
we had that thing now you come back he's
one of those guys actually we did that I
saw that when we tried to bring back the
ultimate warrior in the mid-90s and we
had to go to Phoenix to talk to him and
that was a lot going to a more peaceful
June Jones compound he's also the type
to fire you and then also write the
foreword to your book right yeah and I
you know I did that by text because he's
busy and he always answers me on text
messages he and I we communicate a lot
that way a lot of topics and as I said
we're getting ready to try to
homestretch trying to finish this books
been challenging since Jen's gone I
could give him a mine right and I'm
trying I said would you be interested in
writing the foreword and I promise you
in five minutes
I'd be honored just let to let this
assistant know what the due date is he
said consider it done and so it same
thing I did the same thing Austin its
Austin Rover the back word they say I
think I said backward or whatever it is
and I have coach Bob Stoops write
something Mark Cuban wrote something
Billy Gibbons of ZZ Top wrote something
how nice and so it was a good rock of
course